we were talking about this with the
anthem and what's going on that the
owners decided they were going to tell
the players you know you stay in the
locker room and then all of a sudden
word came out that the NFL Players
Association the players weren't even
consulted on this on what they wanted to
do the owners decided that's it we're
doing it and then a couple of days ago
issuing a grievance there the NFL
Players Association Georgia tala
is the executive assistant executive dry
gotta get you a better title George
George is the assistant executive
director of External Affairs for the NFL
Players Association George good morning
good morning to you Dan that's what's up
explain to me why it took so long for
the Players Association to respond to
what the owner said that they were going
to do pregame with the flag I think we
wanted to take some time and consider
you know any and all of our options if
you noticed we didn't just file the
grievance you know in a vacuum we agreed
to go back to the league and you know
resume conversations is early next week
between members of our executive
committee and league officials and club
owners about potentially finding a
better solution to this we felt like the
conversations that we had back in the
fall in September and October got our
business and got players and owners in a
good place
on this issue and then when things sort
of derailed and management took a
unilateral approach to this that's when
you kind of see you know the crisis back
in the news cycle and you know it's a
good thing that we're gonna get back and
talk about this hopefully we can have
some mutual respect and find some
solutions on it why weren't you
consulted by the owners in the first
place
I don't know I mean you know they sort
of have their meetings we don't exactly
get invited to those meetings with wood
you know as often as we like probably
that's their business you know I think
they decided that it was best for
business or the voices in the room who
came up with this rule probably decided
it was best for business to try to force
players to stand
we certainly don't take that perspective
we want
players to have the opportunity to
express themselves and feel supported
and the NFL more and more is becoming a
game where players are front and center
and that's a good thing for for the
growth of the game and for fans if you
were gonna write it up if you said hey
I'm gonna get all the players together
and this is what the players want to do
how do you think they would vote with
what what we do with the anthem that's
up to them to decide I mean our job and
in the union office is to ensure that
their rights are protected but what do
you think they would do though Georgia
if you said if you put it to a consensus
have you done a poll with the players on
what they would want to do we we haven't
but we know that most of the players
were fine with there not being a rule to
begin with you know we had a number of
players obviously demonstrating where
we've gotten unfortunately far away from
the reasons why those players were
demonstrating and I think you've seen a
tremendous amount of progress made in
terms of the awareness that players have
raised about racial inequality about
social justice about you know criminal
justice reform all of those things have
been able to have progress made on them
because a certain group of players made
a decision to upset the applecart sort
of speak and I think that is something
that we have to get back and focus on I
can tell you this off season we've had
you know our Barb's Association has
supported about a hundred and fifty two
player camps thirty of which had voter
registration drives at them so a lot of
the conversation is about you know
what's going to happen with the rule or
rule change or whatever but where the
players I think feels most strongly
about is the work that they're putting
in on a daily basis to try to improve
their communities we're talking to
George atala he works with the NFL
Players Association of switching topics
LeSean McCoy if we were in the regular
season with what the informations come
out now as opposed to the offseason
what do you think the playing status
would be with LeSean McCoy with the NFL
it's it's disappointing to hear any type
of news like that you never want to hear
about that and you know at any point in
the calendar I think we're still in a
posture of wait-and-see as more facts
are revealed we don't like to jump to
conclusions or even you know posit what
may or may not happen with LeSean or any
other you know headline that you might
hear about that's negative in the
offseason we've been in touch with the
league on it we've been in touch with
LeSean on it and let's let's wait and
see before we we you know unfortunately
we can't be in a position to speculate
so we're just gonna wait for more facts
to come well I'm just speculating like
what would the NFL do because you know
they don't have to wait for all the
information here so I'm just they like
to sit people I knew there was a
commissioner's list here George so that
that's why I'm I'm curious if the NFL
given the information they have there's
enough there that they would just take
him off the football field I think for
for us you know our union is always
going to be in a position to wait and
see what happens with all the facts the
league I think they're gonna have to you
know answer to that question I think you
guys clearly you know can talk about
what may or may not happen we don't have
that luxury I can just be as candid with
you as possible we're still a couple of
days into the revelations about the
incidents that took place and you know
where we are in the offseason camps open
up obviously soon so I think this thing
is gonna you know get into faster motion
years as the Bills head into training
camp yeah it's probably gonna drag into
the season as well George great to talk
to you again we appreciate your time as
always
gentlemen looks forward to having you
here in DC next week George atala NFL
Players Association assistant executive
director for more Dan Patrick show too
it's channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]